I had a really good day recently no is
it an interesting story this is the
story of how I almost threw up in front
of David Mitchell sounds interesting
sounds like it's going to be interesting
probably would be more interesting if I
actually throw up in front of David
Mitchell I'm very pleased that that
didn't happen though I guess for me it's
it's one of those moments that tests
whether or not I'm making decisions in
my life because I want to or because I
think that they will make good videos
and in this in this case I thought you
know what I'm gonna I'm gonna take one
for the team
and no I'm gonna take one for me not for
the team screw the team so I mean the
whole story basically as I went on a
walk with David Mitchell he's a comedian
he's a nice guy as well my friend Ken
introduced me to him he said oh I'm
going on a walking tour of London with
David Mitchell I don't know he speaks
like that he doesn't speak like that
he's American he speaks like this now I
have to do an impression of him Charlie
I'm going on a walking tour of London
the City of London he does actually
sound quite like that but I'm pretty
impressed I'm going on a walking tour of
the City of London with David Mitchell
which you're welcome to come along too
if you would do so desire paraphrasing
obviously a part of me was like I don't
know I don't wanna be moved to know if
your friendship and because can those
look quite a lot of cool people but I
you know I gave him I thought yes I will
come and he was very nice about it but
the problem I have is I have a a very
weak stomach a very bad digestive system
just the act of eating and walking makes
me want to throw up I had lunch with Ken
went on a walking tour of London
we've Ken and David Mitchell spend the
whole thing wanting to throw up we went
to a pub afterwards
David offered to buy me a drink at the
pub and I said can I have a water cuz I
feel quite ill and he said oh I didn't
know you were feeling ill I made him
feel bad and about the fact that I was
feeling ill because I didn't tell him
because I was too embarrassed and then
they both went to go and sit down and I
was like yep I'm gonna go to the toilet
now I sit on the toilet for a little
while I got off the toilet and I threw
up into it I looked at myself in the
mirror I looked like someone who had
just thrown up but I thought well that's
just who I am today I'm the boy who
threw up and when you know I went to say
hello to them I you know for I said yes
I feel a lot better now I didn't say hey
guys I just throw up I just let them
fill in the gaps themselves this is this
is how they
David now you know as well I almost I
almost threw up on you I was a very very
close but held it in and anti a great
guy and to prove this whole story here's
a photo of me with David Mitchell in a
pub we have lots of ties on the ceiling
I didn't even notice the ties until I
saw that photo no idea what the hell
that is
if you want to retrace the steps it was
a pub called the ship or maybe just ship
ship the pub go there and imagine maybe
I should do like an audio tour guide so
you can do the same walking tour that we
did with my internal monologue going on
and on about oh my god I feel so sick
and I frequently sent a weight it was a
great tour he's a very interesting man
he taught me a lot and yeah anecdote
you're welcome
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool by the way
just in case you missed it alright so
one of these isn't it good gonna do it
cuz you know not many people saw this so
that's the way of it sometimes isn't it
it's the trailer from a new short film
click on the thing or don't I mean I'd
like it if you did cuz I'm proud of it
but um yeah alright that's that done